[Musique]
voici laura 23 ans comme tous les matins
elle part travailler en métro mais à
votre avis quel est son métier
d'infirmière
les artistes
devant nous
vous n'y êtes pas du tout
bricolage à domicile
jamais je resterai
et ce jeune homme n'est pas le seul à
être surpris séoul en général ces
clients ont du mal à cacher leur
étonnement je m'attendais pas à trouver
une demoiselle ne sont pas pour tout à
fait courant
je vais vous montrer le travail je vous
ai dit au téléphone ou en tout ça dit
enfin on m'a prévenu luis clerc
la journée commence fort pour laura chez
ce premier client elle va devoir poser
un lustre de 10 kg pour elle c'est la
routine pour son client c'est une autre
histoire
il n'a pas l'air convaincu ça va aller
même le string juste encombrant mais à
chaque fois que je vais chez un client
s'il n'est pas au courant que c'est
effectivement moi qui intervient il est
très surpris et il a un mouvement de
recul un temps d'arrêt demande bien si
c'est moi qui vient terminer si je sais
faire renoncer purement et si le client
a l'air sceptique
notre bricoleuse est parfaitement sûre
d'elle ou son professionnalisme ne fait
aucun doute mais pour son client il n'y
a rien à faire une femme qui fait des
travaux ce n'est pas tout à fait naturel
[Musique]
entretenir encore des heures comme ça
laura n'est pas la seule à exercer un
métier jusqu'ici réservé aux hommes
après s'être fait une place dans les
entreprises les femmes prennent d'assaut
les métiers physiques
emmanuel plombiers électriciens gardes
du corps ou encore masson rien ne les
arrête et tout le monde y trouve son
compte
ils godard et le patron de laura c'est
sa première recrue féminine et pour lui
c'est un vrai plus c'était une volonté
pour nous de refuser ni fille parce que
dans un premier temps dans ce secteur du
bricolage à domicile
on voulait nous aussi se démarquer un
petit peu de la concurrence et dans un
deuxième temps aussi pour apporter une
vraie valeur ajoutée technique dans le
sens où par exemple quelqu'un comme le
rat à cette sensibilité par exemple
décoration ou conseil que des hommes
peuvent - voir
tout faire un excellent et on va essayer
toutes les autres manches
bah écoute et oui parce que ça vous
convient la plupart oui s'il tombe pas
d'ici un mois ou deux encore plus
satisfait merci aux orp a t'on
maintenant trois mois elle pose et si tu
en auras pas la mission de laura est
terminée enfin presque
voilà faut que jean genet outils je
passe un petit col aspirateur
[Musique]
ce alors là
la nature féminine il ne faut peut-être
pas pousser mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'un artisan à 2006 qui nettoie son
chantier ce n'est pas si fréquent
du coup même notre client un poil
machiste semble avoir retourné sa veste
tout comme mon idée du professionnalisme
plus complet que la majorité des hommes
qui ont laissé un trou débrancher pas
passer l'aspirateur et si les femmes se
mettent à faire de l'ombre aux hommes
dans leur domaine de prédilection
en tout cas elles sont de plus en plus
nombreuses dans des professions où on
les attend pas pour les métiers de la
construction
11 % de femmes 17% dans la métallurgie
est encore plus étonnant 5% des
chauffeurs routiers sont aujourd'hui des
femmes etc catalan depuis cinq ans
antalya sillonnent l'europe au volant de
son 40 tonnes sa destination du jour une
carrière du sud de la france où elle
doit livrer du fuel
bonjour oui
j'amène tokyo la thalie à décharge elle
même le fioul chez ses clients
et on ne se rend pas forcément compte
mais c'est extrêmement physique
c'est un coup de main à prendre syrte au
début de courbatures été arrêtés
nombreuses mais là maintenant ça y est
les bras ils ont pris l'habitude à
porter des tuyaux d'une dizaine de kilos
glisser des lis et relis c'est du haut
de son mètre cinquante trois tagliani
n'a rien à envier à un homme
la première fois qu'il a vu le patron de
la carrière a halluciné
au début c'est un petit peu chaud
hélas de l'énergie nous demandent nos
amis des donc savoir les poubelles quoi
même dans les métiers les plus physiques
les femmes donnent le change et ça les
employeurs l'ont bien compris
les recruteurs ont un regard très
bienveillant sur les candidatures
féminines dans ces secteurs là dans la
mesure où sondes sont appliquées
rigoureuse travailleuses sérieux rigueur
et investissement des qualités qui ne
manquent pas alors à résultat la jeune
femme enchaîne les prestations et gagne
1200 euros net par mois fin de journée
laura rentrer enfin à la maison
[Musique]
donc ils vont et viennent et il ya un
ghetto pour trois pages d'un gâteau yao
qui seront valides
puisque dell égal dans cette maison
c'est un peu le monde à l'envers
nicolas en cuisine quand elle aura elle
trouve toujours quelque chose à réparer
dans la maison ce soir ces lampes ou des
toilettes quand on sort du boulot bien
encore à faire ça n'a pas de fin nicolas
lui et commercial et quand il rentre à
la maison ils préfèrent les fourneaux au
marteau une répartition des rôles qui
leur convient à tous les deux c'est
vraiment très bien qu'elle trouvait ce
boulot là parce que ça lui convient
parfaitement
et puis moi je fais à manger et ça me
fait plaisir de lui faire plaisir de lui
faire des bons petits plats et et 100 m
libre donc maintenant que les travaux
sont finis je pouvoir allez prends ma
douche je changeais tille
dix minutes plus tard laura s'est
métamorphosée ce soir à la sortie de
grand jeu car ils reçoivent des amis
alors c'est super pour nicolas c'est un
peu comme avoir deux femmes pour lui
tout seul
en tout cas en tenue de travail ou en
robe sexy
laura est bien la preuve que faire un
métier d'homme ne nuit pas à la féminité